هل سيكون من العدل أن نقول إن
الولايات المتحدة وتلك الدول
التي كانت تحاول الإطاحة
بالأسد في سوريا قد خسرت ذلك
النضال وأن
الإيرانيين الذين كانوا يدعمون
حكومة الأسد انتصروا مرة أخرى كما قال الثاني
إن النظام هو  هناك لتبقى
أم لا ، لا أحد منا يتحدث مع بعضنا البعض حو
ما يج
أن يكون أه قصة أو حو
ر.  والشعب السوري يدفع الثمن
الذي عشناه لسبع أو ثماني
سنوات ، لذلك
علينا أن نعترف بأنه لا توجد
إجابة كاملة ،
لكن المضي قدمًا في الحوار
بطريقة منسقة أفضل من مجرد
المغادرة ، فهل هذا يعني
قسم بحكم الأمر الواقع
حيث يسيطر الأسد على جزء كبير من
سوريا ولكن هناك
جزء يكاد يكون نوعًا من الأراضي الوعرة.
الثيران أو الروس
الموجودون هناك لا يزالون هناك لم يكونوا قد
هزموا ولكن لم يتم تدميرهم
وهذا شيء علينا أن
نتذكره لمضغ العلكة والمشي في
نفس الوقت عندما يتعلق الأمر بهذه
المشكلة ولكن  أعتقد أنه ينظر إلى
الكل في الوقت الحالي هل
هناك مثل هذا الدمار في هذا
البلد أه تعلم أهمية
بناء مدارس لبناء
المستشفيات
وإعطاء الضوء
ولن يكون هناك وقت قريب
بالنسبة للاجئي سيدني ليقولوا حسنًا.  يمكن أن
نعود إلى شيء ما ، لا يوجد شيء
نعود إليه
، ولهذا أعتقد أننا نريد
الابتعاد عن العنف ونرى ما إذا كان لا يمكننا
النظر
في إعادة بناء الكثير من ذلك
سيتم ربطه بالإصلاح السياسي
بقدر ما  كما يمكنني أن أرى
ومرة أخرى لا تنسى وأنت تد
ك المأساة التي تحدث في لبنان وم
يحدث في لبنان أو سوريا مر
بط بالأزمة في لبنان ونحن عل
شفا كارثة إنسانية هن
ك إذا  هذا حسن  لقد حدث بالفعل
والصعوبات التي يواجهها الشعب السوري
نحن في الأردن قد
تواجه موجة أخرى من اللاجئين
لا سمح الله ، لذا فهذه قضايا نحتاج
إلى التعامل معها إذا تجاهلناها ،
فسوف يفاجئنا جلالة الملك ماذا ماذا؟
هل كان الأمر أشبه
باجتماع مع جو بايدن
مقارنة بسلفه ، هذا
رئيس مختلف تمامًا عن الرئيس
الذي كان لدينا من قبل
، لحسن الحظ ، كان
لديّ علاقة قوية جدًا مع جميع
الرؤساء ، وذلك لأن
والدي علمني أن
لديك  لاحترام ضباط
الرئيس
أم رئيس الدولة ، فهذه ليست أمريكا فقط
، وكانت مناقشاتي
مثمرة دائمًا في احترام متبادل وتفهم
الرئيس بايدن الذي أعرفه منذ أن كنت
شابًا
أزور المؤتمر مع والدي
عندما كان  سناتور شاب ،
لذا فهذه صداقة قديمة
وكنت سعيدًا جدًا برؤيته في
البيت
الأبيض وأنا لا أعرف ما هي الصور التي تم
عرضها ولكن  يمكن للبطولات التي كانت معي
أن ترى الكيمياء هناك فقط
وقد عرف ابني
الرئيس ، وبما أن جو بايدن كان
نائب الرئيس ،
اعتاد ابني أن يذهب لزيارته
في منزله وفي مكتبه ، لذا
فهي صداقة عائلية.  توقع
أنك ستحصل
من بايدن على سياسة مختلفة عن سياسة ترامب الجيدة ،
فقد فقدنا بضع
سنوات ، ومن الواضح أن جزءًا منها
كان بمثابة
الوباء ، وبالتالي ليس هناك
مشكلة في سياسة مختلفة ،
إنها أكثر من ما  هي الخطط
الموجودة هناك أم
الثاني ذكرت سوريا أه ولكن أيضًا أه عندما
ننظر إلى لبنان
فإن الأزمة هناك أن الناس
يعانون من الجوع
على وشك أن المستشفيات لا تعمل
وقد أجرينا الكثير من المناقشات
هنا وأنا أعلم أن الأمريكيين يعملون
مع الفرنسيين
عندما يسقط القاع
وسيحدث ذلك في غضون أسابيع ،
ماذا يمكننا أن نفعل بصفتنا
المجتمع الدولي للتدخل لمعرفة أنه
مهما كانت الخطط التي
توصلنا إليها فإننا سنقصر في تحقيق أهدافنا
الأهداف وسنخذل الناس ،
لذا أعتقد أنه يمكننا وضع خطط
لتحريك المنطقة إلى الاتجاه الصحيح نوعًا ما ،
دعني أسألك عن الاستقرار في الأردن
نفسه لأن بلدك غالبًا ما
يُنظر إليه على أنه نوع من جزيرة الاستقرار
في  حي
قاس كان لديك مؤخرًا ما بدا
للعالم الخارجي وكأنه محاولة
انقلاب
ما حدث هناك وما الذي تراه على
أنه احتمالات لأي عدم استقرار
في المستقبل ،
كما تعلمون عندما
ننظر إلى
الأزمات في جميع أنحاء العالم.  العالم وأعتقد أنه في
هذا اليوم وهذا العصر ، نميل إلى النظر إلى
الأزمات على أنها لقطة سريعة دون أن
نفهم حقًا الرحلة التي
قام بها الأردن بالفعل على سبيل المثال
خلال السنوات
العديدة الماضية أه عدم الاستقرار الإقليمي أه
حروب اللاجئين السرية
وكان علينا أن  انظر إلى العديد من
الشخصيات التي تميل إلى استخدام
إحباطات الناس ومخاوفهم المشروعة
من التحديات التي يواجهونها
في تحسين حياتهم لدفع
أجنداتهم وأمبيتهم.  ما أعتقد أنه جعل
هذا
حزينًا جدًا لدرجة أن أحد الأشخاص كان
أخي الذي فعل ذلك بطريقة
هواة
ومخيبة للآمال حقًا من
وجهة نظرنا أه
أجهزة المخابرات حيث يقومون دائمًا
بجمع المعلومات ووصل الأمر إلى  نقطة
كان لديهم فيها مخاوف مشروعة من أن
بعض الأفراد
كانوا يحاولون دفع طموحات أخي
إلى أجنداتهم
الخاصة وقرروا بشكل صحيح تمامًا
القضاء عليها في مهدها وبهدوء
إذا لم يكن ذلك بسبب الطريقة غير المسؤولة
المتمثلة في
تسجيل المحادثات سراً مع
المسؤولين من  الأردن أو نصنع مقاطع فيديو
لك وأنا لن أجري هذه
المحادثة وأعتقد أنك تعلم أنني
فخور حقًا بما يحققه أفراد
عائلتنا عندما يمكنهم
الوصول إلى المجتمع
الآن في هذه الحالة بالذات إذا كان شخص ما
متأكدًا  الطموحات لا يمكنني فعلها سوى الكثير من
أجلهم ،
لكنني أعتقد من وجهة
نظر إنسانية أن الأمر يتعلق بالصدق في
نهاية اليوم
، من السهل جدًا استخدام
شكاوى الناس  للأجندات الشخصية ،
لكن هل أنت مخلص فيما
تحاول القيام به من أجل
شعبك وفي نهاية المطاف ، نتحمل جميعًا
مسؤولية أن نكون قادرين على
التوصل إلى حلول
للناس وهذا ليس فقط محور الأردن
تواجه العائلات المالكة حول العالم هذه التحديات
إذا كنت عضوًا في العائلة المالكة
لديك امتيازات أه تحتاج إلى
احترام
تلك الامتيازات ولكن هناك أيضًا
قيود
وأه السياسة في نهاية
اليوم هي
من اختصاص الملك  أممم ولذا فمن
المؤسف
فقط أم غير ضرورية وخلقنا مشاكل كان من
الممكن أن نتجنبها
أحد الأشخاص الذين كنت جزءًا منها أه
كان قريبًا جدًا من ولي عهد
المملكة العربية السعودية ، هل تعتقد أن هناك
يد سعودية في هذا
أه هذا  يتم النظر إليها على أنها قضية محلية
أم أننا جميعًا نعلم أن أه أه بسام الذي
كان يعمل
في الأردن أه أه كبير مستشاري أه
في السعودية
يحمل جواز سفر سعوديًا وأمريكيًا
شهدنا
علاقات خارجية  حول هذه المسألة
ولكن كما قلت ، نحن نتعامل مع هذا باعتباره
مشكلة محلية وأعتقد مرة أخرى أن معرفة الأردن
أه
توجيه أصابع الاتهام لا يساعد على الإطلاق
لدينا تحديات كافية في المنطقة
نحتاج إلى المضي قدمًا ،
وهذا ما أعتقده دائمًا
الروح الأردنية للتطلع إلى
المستقبل وأعتقد أننا جميعًا نتحدث عن التخفيف من
التحديات
والصعوبات بدلاً من
إضافتك إليها